red blood cells are essential for our
lives so if they've not sure it can be
life-threatening but that's exactly what
happens with paroxysmal nocturnal
hemoglobinuria or PNH a rare blood
disease caused by a Fault in the body's
blood production line the disease
normally appears in adulthood it can
cause a host of symptoms including
anemia blood clots involuntary muscle
contractions and fatigue some of these
symptoms can appear suddenly but the
clearest sign of the disease is the
blood itself when red blood cells
rupture they release hemoglobin which
the body disposes of in the urine this
leads to a concerning dark color
alerting the patient that something's
not right and for unknown reasons this
symptom is usually most visible after a
night's sleep
hence the N in PNH for most patients PNH
has few symptoms for some it can become
life-threatening the red blood cells are
ruptured by the body's own immune system
but what could cause the body to attack
its own blood the trouble starts in the
body's blood making machinery the bone
marrow the bone marrow contains
hematopoietic stem cells these serve as
templates for all the different types of
blood cell like all cells these stem
cells contain a gene called Peter an
essential part of their blueprint it
codes for the part of the cell that
anchors a stamp of authenticity to the
cell surface the complement system is a
part of the immune system that uses
inspectors to check for this stamp on
cells this spam assures the immune
system that the cell is part of the body
not a dangerous invader like a bacterium
or a virus when inspectors or the
stumped on a blood cell everything is in
order
but sometimes the machinery goes wrong
in pmh a mutation in the hematopoietic
stem cells blueprint can derail this
process a faulty pica gene leads to an
incomplete production line and blood
cells that don't have an authentication
stamp the inspectors mistake these cells
for invaders and raise an alarm the
immune system jumps into action
ultimately destroying the cell but this
will only happen to the red blood cells
that come from eight defective stem cell
so long as the majority of stem cells
producing red blood cells still have
well-oiled production lines everything
should be okay but if a lot of stem
cells are end up with this mutation the
body can end up with huge numbers of red
blood cells missing their stamps of
authenticity and that can have
devastating consequences so what can be
done to protect patients and stop their
immune systems from attacking their own
blood cells there are two paths that
treatments can take one is to start from
scratch and replace all of the patient
stem cells faulty and healthier like
that means a bone-marrow transplant but
this is a high-risk strategy if it works
it can cure the disease if it fails it
can have severe consequences the
preferred option is to leave the blood
cells without their spam but to disrupt
the immune system doctors can use drugs
to stop the immune system attacking the
faulty cells this can improve a
patient's quality of life and life
expectancy but it can also hamper the
immune system blocking the inspectors
ability to spot and deal with real
invaders plus the patient needs regular
infusions which can be expensive and
aren't available everywhere so
researchers are still hunting for better
options but even today there are
treatments that can help keep patients
healthy
[Music]